[Music]
my name is Michael I'm with the long now
foundation and I want to wake welcome to
the interval we this is now it's right
about our I think it's our 75th talk
that we've done here since 2014 so for
those of you who it's your first time I
hope you'll follow us and and come back
and see more so Margaret levy is the
tenth director of the Center for
Advanced Study in the behavioral
sciences at Stanford and we have had a
really wonderful partnership over the
last going on three years now that's
seen a number of the current fellows of
the last several classes that have come
and speak on this stage the the center
was founded in 1954 and has produced I
think over three thousand or said more
than three thousand fellows come through
in that time with many names that you
will know from Daniel Kahneman to George
Shultz to Ruth Bader Ginsburg to Norman
Ornstein Edward Tufte Donald Norman and
Steven Lansing Paul Romer and Philip
tetlock so several long now speakers in
those numbers amongst them they've
they've they've won 25 Nobel prizes
they've won 26 national medal of science
Awards 23 pilots there's 51 MacArthur
fellowships literally hundreds of
Guggenheim's and so it's and it's an
incredible resource and frankly for long
now to be able to to connect with some
of the best academics we have around the
world and and bringing some of them here
has been a great collaboration and a
great honor
working with Margaret has been great
because essentially she's in a curation
process which is is a bit what I'm doing
and in producing this series and so we
we meet in that way and we get to think
about which amongst the amazing set of
individuals that are in her series are
going to be a good fit for here but it
also means that curatorial mindset is
perfect for what she's going to do for
us tonight which is actually to look
back at this pursuit that's it at once
an instinct I think that we all have and
at another something that over time
we've developed into quite an amazing
Enterprise one of the great enterprises
of civilizations has produced and I want
to say one more thing about Margaret on
that curatorial side she and her husband
are two of the great collectors of
Australian Aboriginal art so if any of
you are going to be in New York before
the end of the year or in Seattle you
will be able to seek some selections
from their collection the Met has eight
select pieces from from her and her
husband Robert Kaplan's collection that
are currently on show and at San the
Seattle Art Museum there's a large
collection that they've donated over the
years so clearly looking at humor and
enterprise and excellence all across the
board we're in great hands tonight
please give a big round of applause for
Margaret
and what I want to talk about tonight is
obviously the organized pursuit of
knowledge and I'm gonna start backwards
and then go forwards and we're gonna
make some steps forwards and some steps
back as we think about that process and
I'm gonna emphasize two themes
throughout the first is really that
there are two big issues that at least
from me pervade all efforts at organized
knowledge
the first one is normative in a sense
it's how do we produce better societies
how do we design them how do we govern
them what kinds of values do they have
what kinds of virtues do they represent
how do we build a political economy
that's also a moral economy that really
speaks to those issues now to do that we
really have to understand our world we
have to build from what's realistic and
that's the second theme and I'm gonna
start by focusing on the second theme
about how we see and how we understand
and then build to the other one come
back to the other one so I'm gonna use
two metaphors in thinking about this
problem underlying that is we need lots
of tools to see lots of tools to
understand to see both what can be seen
and to see what we cannot see but is
necessarily a building block of what
we're gonna do
so the first metaphor if you will is the
one that Otto did for us which is the
telescope and the microscope and what
they represent quite obviously and
evidently is an ability to look wide and
to see a big picture and an ability to
look deep and to look really inside and
often to in both cases to reveal things
we could not see with the naked eye but
they do two different things and we need
both right to really understand the
world we need to be able to do both the
other metaphor I'm going to use there it
is
is the blind man of ancient India often
I mean the Jews thought they were the
man of Hjelm but they're actually old
Indians ancient Indians from that
civilization and you know this story
they can't identify the elephant in the
room right they're all looking at
different pieces of the elephant once
these feels the tail one feels the skin
one feels the hoof they don't have a
model they don't know how to
conceptualize what they're seeing they
don't know how to come work together
even to build a picture of what that is
so that's the other metaphor to have an
organized pursuit of knowledge that
actually produces knowledge that matters
that we care about you need to be able
to put together the pieces of what
you're seeing and again that requires
some collaboration some team effort
multiple disciplines multiple ways of
thinking about things
so how do we organize knowledge to serve
these joint ends of design and of seeing
okay and that's what I'm really going to
talk about so let me give you a little
bit of history first you've learned that
we collect my husband and I collect
Australian Aboriginal art and so I
couldn't help but refer to that and
refer to that culture in this talk
because when we think about systematic
knowledge and the way in which it's
passed to other generations from the
elders to the younger it's not just a
question of building universities we've
had ways of passing on systematic
knowledge forever
so these rituals that the Australian
these are fairly modern Australian
Aborigines but what they're doing is
something that their culture has been
doing for fifty thousand years as a way
to reveal what can't always be seen they
have a problem they have to get through
the desert they have to find the water
they're in small bands of hunters and
gatherers and they have to convey what
the land is like so wherever you are you
can find the water you can find your way
out you can find back to the corroboree
and the group and so they use pink they
use songs they used getting together in
larger groups and their hunting and
gathering bands that pass on the
knowledge this is just a picture of the
dancing knowledge gets codified maybe
six thousand years ago with the Jews
and we get the Talmud which is also a
lot of arguing and a lot of
collaboration and a lot of disagreement
but creating a law creating a written
law but we become modern if you will in
our organized pursuit of knowledge and
I'm just gonna refer to the Western
tradition here largely there are other
traditions there's there's a Chinese
tradition an Indian tradition there are
many other traditions in the world but
I'm gonna refer to the Western tradition
and how it organized there was the
pursuit of knowledge so we really start
with the Greeks maybe they're the Greeks
so that's Plato and Aristotle from a
famous Renaissance painting which wasn't
done at the time they were alive in case
you mix up your history there so the
symposia is a really important
institution that gets created with the
ancient Greeks and again it's what's
really different about this from what
the Australian Aborigines we're doing is
that it's a very active critical process
it's about asking questions it's not
just about passing on knowledge or
passing on the law even though there was
questioning always about that but it's
really about creating an environment in
which critical thinking is absolutely
crucial in which the whole basis of the
Socratic method is challenges and
questions so people learn from each
other they learn from their mistakes and
they learn from the progress that they
each make they become members of a group
of a colloquia that is dedicated to
discovery to pushing the boundaries of
what they understand and what they know
but critical thinking is really the key
to this process and that's what we're
gonna follow that train the curious mind
the scientific mind begins to emerge but
in these early stages you don't see all
the specializations that we now see
think about Aristotle or later da Vinci
these are people who pull together all
of the sciences Natural Sciences
Sciences philosophical sciences economic
sciences they're part of the same
process they're part of one big whole
they look at human behavior and they
look at the ways in which humans
interact and they put it in the natural
world and in the larger world and
they're looking both inward and outward
deep and wide trying to see the moving
parts but also trying to understand the
whole they're trying to do that to
understand yes that's a critical part of
what they're up to but they also are
working very hard to figure out how to
design a better world how to use that
knowledge as the building blocks of
really thinking about how to what
governance should look like what
cooperation engenders and how its
created okay so now we move again and we
move to the universities this is a
university in Fez created in the 9th
century I won't even try to pronounce
its name chorion I think it's arguably
the first University in the world but
the one get gets the distinction in most
history books is this one Bologna which
was created in 1088 so we're in the 11th
century the 10th and 11th century we see
the burgeoning of universities but there
in a sense a step backward though
they're gonna move us many steps forward
ultimately their religious institutions
they don't require questioning they
require just passing on the knowledge
the writ what is accepted and they're
extremely exclusive it's not the
universities open up all that fast but
these are really a very small group of
people who are allowed to possess this
kind of knowledge to see the books that
are written down to have access to
information so universities begin as
very very exclusive places as opposed to
places that are open to really bringing
up all the questions and allowing
everybody in to ask those questions
the next real move is a big bang for the
organized pursuit of knowledge where we
begin to have some really serious
scientific advance it's not that this is
the first scientific advance obviously
there's Galileo there's lots of people
who precede this but in 1816 57 or
they're in the 1650s we get the
publication of William Harvey's de moto
cordis on the motion of heart and blood
he has looked inside the body he has
figured out a way in which blood
circulates this is a huge advance this
is something you couldn't see you could
only see it I mean once you took a dead
body and took it apart you might you
couldn't see the blood it was gone so he
had to infer it he had to use science he
had to use tools that were available and
it's the beginning of a major explosion
right this this leads to the
Enlightenment and we begin which is in
the late 17th century into the mid 19th
century and we get a huge amount of new
kinds of ways of thinking of learning we
get the the science of Newton and many
others we get the social philosophy of
Locke humor or so and many others we get
the economics and social sciences again
Hume one of the great figures in all of
this history and Adam Smith and Jeremy
Bentham and many others the next step
forward is really with liberal arts and
graduate education which are 19th
century creations largely there's
greater inclusion
there's breadth but also specialization
this is a year of the classic education
where every young man of a certain class
had to learn Greek and Latin but also
Snatcher 'el science and philosophy but
they were still very exclusive
institutions in terms of gender race
class right so this is Rosa Luxemburg
one of my great here wins how many of
you have ever heard of Rosa Luxemburg my
students have heard of her
one of least one of whom is here Rosa
Luxemburg was a very important political
economist at the turn of the the early
part of the 20th century the last part
of the 19th her death was by drowning
she was murdered by the germans at the
end of World War one because of her
social beliefs she was a Democrat social
democrat she was a socialist she was a
communist and fought with limb Lenin had
a different view of organizing she was a
very ambitious woman who wanted to go to
graduate school and she found in this
wonderful graphic novel called red Rosa
this is the image from that she found
that there was a graduate school that
accepted women the University of Zurich
and so she went to the University of
Zurich and graduated from there with a
PhD in 1887 just to give you a sense so
that it wasn't that long ago right how
hard it was for women to get an
education
another hero win of mine is Gertrude
Stein who went to Radcliffe studied with
William James so she learned psychology
and philosophy then went to Hopkins
Medical School because it was one of the
only place as a woman could go on and
get a degree she was bored there and
left to go to Paris to become the
Gertrude Stein we know using some of the
things she learned from William James in
the process of writing her poetry my own
experience in getting an education
involved a place called Western High
School in Baltimore it was the first
public high school that women could
attend I was not in the first class that
was in 1844 Walt Whitman gave the
convocation speech but it was it still
exists and it's got this very long
history was created as a place where
women women could go there was an
Eastern and a western because women
couldn't travel very far from where they
lived and it really prepared women to be
teachers not University teachers
teachers of young children and it grew
from that so it became one of the famous
places for college preparatory work a
pub
Highschool right others followed suit I
then chose to go to Bryn Mawr College
which had a similar history but for
universities founded in 1855 again I was
not in the first class though I am
getting close to feeling like I was and
it was a place that was the first
college for women that did two things
one it followed the Harvard model in
terms of standards so it was the highest
standard of any place that women could
go and the second thing it did was
provide the first graduate program at a
women's college so it's one of the first
and only places women could get a
college a grad both a college education
of a very high quality and a graduate
education so that's what formed me so
you can see why I care about these
issues of exclusion this is james
Meredith and Ole Miss just to remind you
about how recently our universities were
exclusive this is not that long ago this
is the 1960s now there were exceptions
Harvard was founded as an Indian College
Native American College there were the
historically black colleges that got
formed but nonetheless until very very
recently colleges and universities in
the United States as well as elsewhere
were extremely exclusive they've opened
up they really opened up in the
post-world War two ERA more than any
other time they also had another problem
there was a tendency towards over
specialization and scholasticism that
began to develop so how many of you read
Middlemarch my favorite character in
Middlemarch in some way so he's awful is
this desiccated scholar named Cass Alban
who marries the beautiful woman she
thinks he's the epitome of everything
wonderful until she realizes he's not he
cannot finish his books his books are
boring by the time he does them nobody
cares they're outdated that's
scholasticism writ large this is
actually a picture of John Locke who
people
but the people think what was what cuz
Obon was based on okay to go back okay
so people kept searching I mean here
were these exclusive universities and
they were in many ways scholastic from
the popular viewpoint they weren't
legible they weren't accessible so
people kept searching for better ways to
learn and better ways to research and
there were a number of ephemeral
solutions that developed but they're
interesting models for how to think
about what we can do and particularly as
we move forward
one was the Chautauqua of the 19th
century which were it's basically a
moving lecture sort of summer camp of
information and lecturing others which
have developed more recently in the 21st
century or perhaps the modern-day
equivalents
maybe MOOCs are they ephemeral are they
here to stay I don't know but they
certainly have a Chautauqua kind of
feeling of a way to reach out to a lot
of people to be entertaining to gather
you together but you're doing it as an
individual watching something that a lot
of other people are watching so it
doesn't have quite the same feeling
something that does is the makers
movement there's things going on where
people get together in fairs and they
share information that maybe I don't
know if it's ephemeral but it's another
way to try to find learning and to do
research that's outside of the confines
of the university the 20th century we
get other kinds of things that have
developed one which unfortunately turned
out to be ephemeral we'd hoped it would
last longer were the corporate funded
research centers such as Bell Labs and
Xerox PARC which when they were at their
heyday they were outside the university
though they drew on people who'd been
trained in the universities but in their
heyday they were really the places where
incredible innovation in science
particularly not so much in social
science occurred we also see in the 20th
century the development of Institute's
for Advanced Study of course had to get
that in the first one is the answer
for Advanced Study that's at Princeton
sorry I need some water to talk about
for instance so Princeton was started in
the 1930s and it's model was really one
of permanent faculty who were super
famous and the Advanced Study really
referred to the fact which it still
refers to for all of us who have such
places that they were gonna go beyond
the boundaries of what was already known
and what had already been studied they
were gonna Advanced Study well beyond
that an Advanced Research so famous
names affiliated with the Institute for
Advanced Study were largely very
important emigrates from what was
happening in Europe at that time so Anse
Einstein von Neumann etc okay so they
started the Institute for Advanced Study
the second Institute for Advanced Study
in the world was the Center for Advanced
Study in the behavioral sciences which
came in in the 1950s I'm looking at Bob
because if I say something wrong he'll
get me he'll slap me down tell me what's
right okay so so we were the second and
but we had a very different model we
came out of the Ford Foundation of Ford
Foundation committee that was looking at
how to use the new tools and methods
that had been developing in social
science how to look deep and how to look
wide and in the heyday of the optimism
of the post-world War two ERA to create
something that would really enable
social scientists to contribute their
knowledge to human welfare back to our
one of our original themes and so the
Center for Advanced Study was what was
created and it's a beautiful place on a
hill overlooking Stanford and you should
all come visit if you haven't really is
gorgeous mid-century institution but the
idea there was not to have permanent
faculty I am still the own I'm the only
permanent faculty at the Center for
Advanced Study in behavioral science it
was to bring together really brilliant
minds to be interred
Disciplinary from many Social Sciences
some sciences some humanities to be in
the same place to have lunch together to
walk together at one point to play
volleyball together they don't do that
anymore Bob so much they play ping pong
though and to really start thinking new
ways of approaching really critical
issues and that's still our mission this
day and there are several fellows and
former fellows in the audience and I
encourage you all to meet up with them
they are brilliant minds ok so the next
question I want to ask is has make sure
I'm still in time has the organized
pursuit of knowledge really delivered do
we see better do we understand more have
we built better designs at best the
pursuit of knowledge encourages critical
thinking often sometimes leading to
tolerance of new ideas to innovation to
challenges to the status quo though
sometimes those whose challenge the
status quo aren't happy personally with
the consequences think Socrates having
to drink the hemlock but we've continued
to chase people out of universities who
think too critically at its best it does
what Abraham Flexner the first director
of the institute for advanced study
called the usefulness of useless
knowledge you let people do their thing
you don't know what it's gonna come to
and lo and behold some of that turns
into things that change our world that
change all kinds of tools we have
changed the way we think you know about
Einstein von neumann von Neumann I had
goat go tools but what about some of
caspases past fellows Michael mentioned
a few of them Tversky and Kahneman arrow
Rawls Philip tetlock who recently spoke
in a salt lecture what we try to do in
these kind in the best of places of
organized pursuit of knowledge whether
it be our Center or a university is to
create an environment in which they can
flourish by trying things and flourish
by learning new ways of seeing as well
as new
problems I was gonna talk about some of
my own research topics some of the
arcane stuff that you can see in the
book that John Alquist and I wrote but I
think first for lack of time I will just
move on I'm glad to answer questions or
talk to you over drinks which I'm
looking forward to after I finish giving
this talk but the organized pursuit of
knowledge is sometimes its own worst
enemy can be hierarchical and
patriarchal it can have problematic
research incentives slow not so risky so
that you get tenure and there also has
produced as we've seen recently some
real frauds who bring down the good name
of social science and science generally
so what does the future look like that's
the present and we need to go beyond
that and really deliver more so given
the base line shifts beginning in World
War two so the mid-century we've seen a
number of things happen which we have to
understand in order to figure out about
the future oneness there have been big
changes in popular and government
demands about what who education should
deliver to and what it should deliver
we've seen the expectations of a mass
education we've seen changes in funding
that tends to reward things that will
deliver more immediately not so much the
usefulness of useless knowledge but
really pragmatic can we get to the moon
can we build a better light bulb can we
do this or that can social science
provide a piece of data that will answer
some specific question foundations have
fallen into that trap
certainly government has and we're
seeing a lot more even more emphasis
than we saw in the 50s on meeting the
needs of private sectors particularly I
think the technology sector so we're
confronted with a number of challenges
that we need to overcome let me start
with the challenges and then head to the
scenarios of what might happen
we have corporations who refused to
share data appropriately and even more
importantly we have dis
belief of scientific discoveries in part
because of hype this is based on the
Gartner hype curve it's it's done by a
Nobel Prize winner named Ben zyk who
actually created one of the great
several of the great microscopes and has
a fabulous talk about that and so we're
seeing this incredible amount of hype
all the time about particular
discoveries or expectations of
discoveries or other things that doesn't
help us because it leads to unjustified
claims whether it be a study that Kari
and I were just talking about about
living wages in Seattle leave it leading
to restaurants having worse health
conditions which is not true but was
hyped and got a lot of attention and
cited several times on NPR as an
authoritative study but that kind of
hype doesn't help us so we see all kinds
of promises not kept expectations not
met I think about education policies all
the things that we've been told will
solve our education problems that have
failed to do so so that leads to
disbelief in what social science can
actually produce and that's a challenge
for us but there's the big challenge is
how do we get all of us and the larger
public to really understand that science
is never going to be absolute our
findings are never gonna be the end
result I was mentioning before this
started think about Pluto we were sure
it didn't exist and then we saw it and
it was a planet and then we saw it
better and it wasn't a planet but that's
the nature of science you have theories
you refute them you try again you refute
them again it's gonna be that kind of
process and that requires a different
kind of understanding from the public as
well as from our students as well as
from our practitioners about what
science is all about so where are we
heading there's a scenario I really
don't like but it could be the one we're
in
or heading for increasing bifurcation
between elite privates and underfunded
publics all over the world class
stratification increased again real
opportunities decreased a move towards
STEM vocational education and away from
the value of liberal arts widely and
correctly understood of critical
thinking of seeing both deep and wide
the one I want to achieve the scenario
I'd like to see us move toward in which
I hope in some ways casbahs can
contribute to has the end goals of even
greater evidences based on real
scientific thinking and not just
intuitive common sense and unfounded
beliefs a lot of what we see occurring
whether it be about the benefits of
coffee how many times have we read
coffee's good fresh coffee snuff good
first coffee it's good for us it's good
for women it's not good for women or
other sources or the sort myths we hear
about the sources of racism or populism
Zoar war we've really got to get those
things down the requirements I think are
real interdisciplinarity not just
bringing people together to lunch as we
did in the early days of the Center for
Advanced Study and thinking the multiple
disciplines would actually just somehow
attract each other sometimes they did in
various ways but what we really want is
to think about problems in an
interdisciplinary way think about the
big problems that are confronting us and
bring together people who come from
multiple perspectives multiple
disciplines multiple methods some of
whom are in academia and bring that
knowledge to bear some of whom are
journalists or who are in industry or in
government who bring that knowledge to
bear and their sets of questions to bear
and have a real conversation about that
and make real advances that serve both
that means we we would develop real
collaborations perhaps achieving what
John Seely Brown and Anne Pendleton
Julian sitting here in the front row
talk about as networks of imagination a
lovely term in which we can really
advance solutions on wicked problems and
the capacity to see both deep and wide
to see back to the microscope and the
telescope if you will and understand
what we are seeing how it is distorted
how it can be clarified if we have the
right tools the attention can't be only
to technology perhaps more importantly
and this is I really want to emphasize
this and this is where something like
has this really comes in in to how
humans think how humans interact how
humans build and destroy societies we
need to bring the human back into the
science and the technology not just the
effect on the humans but how humans
actually interact with all of that and
make things different
what casbahs can do and several of my
co-conspirators are in this room is to
really try to work towards the
development of a new moral economy and
that leads to a whole bunch of different
projects that we currently have on the
future of work and workers not just work
but the people who are doing the work
and what's gonna happen to them to the
social life of climate change not just
the natural life but how people are
affected and how they can affect through
both mitigation and adaptation policies
informed by evidence where what we know
about humans and how they will react the
policies comes into the story issues of
Technology society in the human etc so
let me conclude we need this is a
wonderful painting that Dennis Evans did
who's an artist in Seattle did for my
class a casbahs he came and interviewed
all this was 93 94 he came and
interviewed all of us and he tried to
represent our class in this painting and
it's we use it a lot to sort of
represent what Casbah
is all about the book the tree of
learning the variety of disciplines the
variety of issues that we study we need
good social science we need it
good science about the human and human
interactions to inform public policy to
generate realistic assessments of what's
wrong and right with the world I
attended a conference this morning and I
was struck by how all these incredibly
smart people were there but how they
tended to and they were saying really
interesting things and then they would
say something about social science or
social science issue and they would draw
on the worst pop social science they
really didn't have a good grasp of but
we got to change that we've got to make
sure all of us really understand what we
know and what we don't know and how to
use it
I everyone wants to claim now that they
understand Tversky and Kahneman for
example you've all read Michael Lewis is
the undoing project you got it down
right well it's a little more than that
so we need to be attentive to how to do
good social science and we need to be
attentive to how to convey what we've
learned so we need to see wide and deep
up close and far away as I keep
emphasizing and integrating those ways
of seeing into the elephant in the room
back to the ancient man of India in a
continual and very difficult process
because it means constant challenge
constant rethinking what we're seeing
rician what we think we saw that makes
us susceptible to hype and to fads
social science is the we here it makes
us susceptible to accusations of
khalaqtu sysm scholasticism and really
useless knowledge it can breed confusion
even disbelief among the public about
the benefits of good science but it's
still worth doing and we've got to learn
how to do it better and right and to
convey it better but I think the really
hard task still lies ahead and that's
taking what we've learned and
reintegrating it as Aristotle did with
the state of knowledge of his time
we've got to bring all the pieces back
together into one hole and to make all
those studies all that in a sense was
useless knowledge come together to form
how we design our societies and to chart
our path into the unknown future
thank you I know there's at least one
question in the room because he asked it
before so yeah so we we definitely some
time for questions we also have our
livestream I want to thank folks they're
listening on the livestream
and I've got a an iPad that's gonna tell
me your questions so go ahead and ask in
the chat and hopefully we can get some
of your questions in before please think
of your questions I got a couple things
I want to start I actually want to talk
for a second more about casbahs so okay
I know you won't argue with that but
I've had a chance to to see a bit about
cosmos and understand a little bit more
the mechanics I don't think in passing
most people would and it fascinates me
because in some ways there's some direct
parallels with what what we are doing
and specifically what we're doing in
this place
and having a social atmosphere around
ideas so I think probably most people in
this room have some exposure to academia
whether you're in it or have a relative
or something that's in it and went
through it yeah yeah or running away
from it but there's there's a tendency
toward or a danger of siloing and
there's there's a just like any
collegial group that there's an insular
ness that tends to happen what what
fascinates me is that the structure of
casbahs the way it's set up inherently
kind of breaks against that because
they're these scholars are taking this
fellowship year to to come to a
different institution or even if there's
someone who's a fellow economist or
sociologist there they probably come
from a different thing they're meeting
each other with different experiences
and it kind of shakes up their
experience can you say a little bit
because I'm
curious about there's also again the
interesting here the direct social
interaction of the individuals is kind
of structurally built into it and also
the the orations the the talking about
their work is also something you require
from the fellows can you just say a word
about kind of how the how the fellowship
your works out for sure though their
fellows here can say something about
that to look at the real story later so
we've just started our fellowship class
it just began two weeks ago and what we
always start with is making it clear to
people who arrive that whatever they
think they're gonna do that year let it
go
think about what be affected by one the
time that you finally have to really
think in a different way and by these
incredible individuals who are all
around you and that if you're lucky you
will think really differently at the end
of the year I can't predict how people
will think or how they will change and
some it'll be a small amount that
matters a lot and some will be a lot I
mean they'll just totally transform the
kind of work they're doing but we try to
create an environment and that's been
true for a very long time probably from
pretty close to the beginning an
environment where people have that right
and are encouraged to really be able to
to be the next person they want to be as
a thinker we encourage that further by
there's only there only two requirements
at casbahs for the fellows in Bob's time
it was to play volleyball lunch
but that's no after lunch but that's no
longer the case
ours is having lunch together three or
four times a week and we have a very
constrained time for lunch 12:00 to
12:30
there's no food for you after 12:30
Barbie will not let you take food after
12:30 we don't want people sitting in
their offices and saying I was trying to
finish this paragraph and it's 1 o'clock
and this is when I feel like eating
because we want people to interact with
each other there's a sub rule in there
so I'll slip in a third
roll here before I get to the second one
so this is 1a which is that even though
there are clusters of people also at
casbahs now who were working together or
working on common projects they're not
allowed to have their work meetings at
lunch right they're supposed to be
interacting with the other fellows the
second rule is they have to attend and
they have to be at lunch three or four
times a week
the second rule that we have is that
they have to attend each other's
seminars every fellow gives the seminar
it's talking about his or her research
and that's an absolute requirement
occasionally one is missed by someone
but that's how people play try out their
ideas we learn about each other we
interact with each other and try to form
something bigger than the whole now
something has changed since its first
days I was recruited actually to
reimagine casbahs for the 21st century
it was a mid 19th century institution
the way I like to say it is if you look
at the first class of fellows you can
point out the one woman if you really
look hard but it's basically a group of
white men of a certain age who wrote
great books and did it individually with
research assistants sometimes with their
wife who didn't often get credit so if
you look at the class now it's
incredibly diverse its diverse in age
its diverse in not just disciplines
that's always been true it's
international its gender diverse its
racially diverse its diverse in just
lots of different kinds of ways so
that's been one big change but what I
really changed was or have been
attempting to change is to create an
environment where we can have some
ongoing if you will symposia some
ongoing discussions around some
important themes I named some of them in
my talk and to really institutionalize
that so there might be a fellow or to
Sarah's part of a group Sarah Ogilvie
who's a linguist and she's here for the
year she won't be a fellow next year she
wasn't a fellow next year last year but
the group that she's
part of has a lifespan of three to five
years let's say and will be based to
casbahs have meetings there pull in
fellows who she meets this year that an
institution within the institution in a
way right yeah but it has to be
integrated with the rest it has to be
constantly playing off others who are
they're learning from other people who
are there to create that kind of
environment both as a model and a
possibility a proof-of-concept if you
will and will take a question from the
audience in a second we've got the the
mic right there so just let you know so
just for folks that may not I guess we
kind of have the disciplines that are
typically there in this and this work of
art but what are the what are the
disciplines that it's usually well
that's the core social sciences are I
start with political sciences because
I'm a political scientist political
science sociology psychology
anthropology economics and history thank
you Carrie I wasn't gonna leave out
economics economics is an important in
history but we've we've often had people
from literature people from philosophers
philosophers are regularly there we
often have philosophers we've had groups
of biologists we've had some physicists
it really varies from year to year
architects so let's talk about snow for
a moment snow biologists and physicists
are there two cultures how do you bridge
them are there ten thousand cultures and
are you guys doing anything about this
fake news and attention subversion
economy so this is two two-part question
two cultures right so of course there
are two cultures they still I mean
specialization is still with us and on
all the linguistic divides as well as
conceptual divides between the two I'm
doing a lot of work right now with
engineers so we also now have at the
center and and some work as well with
some people who are studying the ocean
so by
August and others and the first thing
we've got to do in those cases and I
think this is true of the fellows and
all of the groups we've created is find
a common language make sure that the
concepts that we're talking about make
sense to each other sometimes it turns
out I was just having a conversation
with a computer scientist that I'm
working with I said something about
beliefs and he described it in another
functional something another and then we
had to figure out whether what we were
saying was exactly the same thing it
turns out it wasn't but the language was
a divide that was giving us a false
sense of understanding as opposed to a
true sense of misunderstanding that
could be corrected so the first thing we
have to do in any of these
interdisciplinary groups is overcome
that and give people space to learn
enough from each other and to trust each
other enough and part of it is we're
never gonna all become specialists in
each other's area we don't want to be
that's not advantageous in this world I
mean there are things that people really
know deeply that we want them to know
deeply and they bring that into the
conversation we have to find a way that
to take all of those ingredients and
meld them into something better without
destroying the kinds of knowledge that
people gained and need to gain in order
to really make that happen so that's the
first question it's not it's a process
and it's a hard one and we have to do it
we just have to do it the second
question about false news and the
various ways in which information is
misunderstood
yes we've struggled with that problem at
Casper's I don't think we're necessarily
I mean one of the things we're
constantly doing there and there's
certainly fellows who are thinking about
those issues and former fellows who are
but one of the things we always do with
our projects is to try to find our niche
is to find something that we can do that
others either aren't doing aren't doing
well or where we would be complimenting
something else that's going on and so
the false news one for example we have
thought a lot about and had some
projects had some
workshops around that but decided there
are other groups that are really doing
that and we can send people to those
groups from our network and if the issue
transforms in a way that makes sense for
us to be thinking about it we'll do that
but that doesn't mean that our that the
social scientists who are act as person
had been at Cass person will be AK as
vez this Akron caspase is the Center for
Advanced Study in behavioral science
it's a really unfortunate acronym but
it's so be it
you know what we a lot of them are
thinking about the ways in which beliefs
are formed the ways in which people
generate ideologies or echo chambers or
other ways that line them from making
discernments about the sources of
information and whether it's credible
information or not so I see our fellows
is constantly contributing to trying to
solve or advance hardly ever get a full
solution but advance on the kinds of
questions that are really disturbing
people today hope that was making
creating a better society right so I was
wondering if knowledge not know it's
probably usually usurps creating a
better society but what if the two were
ever in conflict like what's the
ultimate goal here is it really the
pursuit of knowledge or is it creating a
better world if the two are ever in
conflicts of you take a hypothetical
case the thought experiment in
philosophy and well you knew that
acquiring a certain piece of knowledge
would be bad for them the society that
you'd create with it afterwards which
one would you ditch because for my
background right I always thought that
like not even the pursuit of knowledge
but also over sharing of knowledge is
really important and it's usually good
the net benefit but now I sometimes find
that you might not want to make all the
knowledge of
available knowledge could hurt if it's
the wrong time so I'm really grappling
with that fact of knowledge as a pursuit
in itself and the value of it versus its
value for creating a better society and
what to choose it's a great question and
I want to evade it is my deep instinct
and believe that the two are totally
compatible but I think you're right that
there can often be a conflict between
the two but I don't think it's actually
my instinct is it's not actually a deep
conflict if the design of the rules of
our society are good and actually
functioning for us so you're really
emphasizing the accessibility of
knowledge more than the pursuit of
knowledge so I think the pursuit of
knowledge is almost always good I mean
in the scientific process when you make
things available it may be a different
kind of decision because you don't want
to fall into the hype you don't want to
promise something you can't deliver on
so there's very complicated process
about I mean this is a society that
likes one we live in right the second
likes instantaneous information so the
belief that you have to share something
the minute you've discovered it I think
is problematic we need to keep testing
it we need to refine it we need to
understand the context under which it
works and doesn't work and then it's
shareable so I don't think ultimately
the two are in conflict but I don't
think it's always easy to resolve that
tension and as we're getting our next
question you talked about really good
social science kind of where you
concluded can you say another word about
that because I think we all know what
the scientific method is in a general
sense but for for social science isn't
for 21st century social sciences with
new data tools and new technologies that
come out there you say a word about what
what defines or denotes what some of the
best practices are or what you know how
do you if you're evaluating or
critiquing something that you're like
at this study something I never have to
do yes my husband believes that all we
academics do all day long and all week
long is critique other people's work and
write reviews of it and evaluations and
there's something to be said for that so
what criteria do we use I mean that's
that's the deep question and how do we
advance the best practices so social
science is not you know I'm using it as
a big tent but there are lots of
different pieces in that tent just as so
it's it's multiple cultures even within
social scientists the way economists
think and kind of model that they
generally use is different than the way
an anthropologist thinks and the kinds
of multiple models the different kinds
of anthropologists use so Jamie Jones
who does more physical anthropology
thinks really differently than a social
anthropologist right so you've got
really different methods going on even
within the social sciences but all of
them ultimately have to meet certain
standards so it I think we've generally
agreed on are the best scientific
practices it's not just social science
it's generally science of which social
science is part which is refutation the
capacity to be able to refute something
that sometimes it's created by data and
it's data-driven
but sometimes it's about a couple it's
observational sometimes it's based on
fieldwork
but you have to be able to set it up in
a way that somebody could challenge it
that somebody could which gets back to
the question of you know when do you
disseminate that knowledge you really
want to be able to feel confident enough
about it or that you've done all the
work you can and and considered all the
possibilities so I think that that
capacity to refute and that that's
written into it as a crucial part of it
part of it is using the best tools
available for seeing that we have now so
when there is data available I mean I
I'm a big believer in multiple methods I
think you know if you have an multiple
collaborators if you have a problem the
best way to approach it is to bring in
all
the tools and all the people who can
help you figure it out to argue among
each other until you actually make an
advance that's a traditional science
tool you know we're just beginning to
move to that kind of model in social
science and I advocate that we have
another question hey David so my
question is to what extent are you
looking around for clues outside in the
sense that you look at the music
industry and their music was generated
one way for a long time than Napster or
an iTunes
mm-hmm this whole thing's there it's a
social science problem right yeah you
can see it all around see these
different kind of clues and trends and
and in all of those cases the way that
the kind of institution got blown up was
from an outsider so to what extent are
you bringing in outsiders to this to
this process if you are at all we are we
are at all so again the way our
collaborative groups are organized is
some of them are just academics but most
of them are not they're involving people
who've really come at this problem a
totally different way they may be from
government they may be from industry
they may be from singularity Paul Sappho
is part of the future of working workers
group who brings a whole different
perspective and set of questions than an
academic would bring but it's been
crucial to our process that those
questions are coming from all over the
place that we're open and this is part
of the scientific method to that you're
open to what's really going on not just
to the little thing that you're looking
at you need both the telescope and the
microscope right you can't just be
looking at your own little piece of cell
or earth you have to understand how that
cellar earth fits into a larger hole so
that's Akoo I mentioned who developed
these incredible new microscopes works
very closely with biologists because he
can't figure out what the microscope can
really do and what it's distorting
unless somebody who knows what they
think they should be seeing can inform
him so we can't do it by ourselves and
we have to get that information and that
disruption from every source that we can
that is part of the really good social
science method it's to be open to all of
that possibility and then to discipline
it to the extent we can until it's
disrupted again and by the way I think
that if I'm not wrong
how music got free was written out about
the mp3 things work say a moment about
your own work in political science this
we've got your book I believe your
collaborator is also a guest fellow this
year so can you say something about your
work and maybe also about you know how
that maybe led to I mean this is the way
that you were looking at political
science have anything to do with your
ending up as as director of hope I
haven't ended up but thank you Michael
the weigh station yeah I don't know
what's next
I can imagine anyway so my own work well
in in some ways it illustrates what I
mean by the the method in social science
so I am deeply interested which may not
surprise you from my emphasis on moral
economy on the relationships between
citizens and government or subjects and
their states depending on the historical
period and the interactions between them
and how they influence each other and
why you see compliance sometimes and
non-compliance and rebellion at other
times and I've looked at and and how you
change beliefs that question about false
news how you create environments in
which people come to believe that they
can act in ways they didn't know they
could act in that the world is different
than they thought it was or how they
come to believe that it's a really
narrow
that they should only act on narrow
economist ik interest so those are the
kinds of questions that compel me but to
answer those questions required me to
look at very specific and if you will
arcane things not so arcane taxes
conscription and military service as way
and and ultimately at the book that John
and I wrote is looking at labor unions
as a way because labor unions are many
governments right and the interest of
others anyway so and I can tell you
where this comes from because it's I
will do that in a second but we look at
those things as a way to understand the
mechanisms and dynamics it's a way to
reveal the cellular structure if you
will and the the mechanics of how
cooperation happens how resentment
distrust non-cooperation takes place but
to do that you've got to really
understand it if you will at a very
detailed level and then sort of write it
out and figure out where it can apply in
other kinds of context in larger kinds
of systems and so in the interest of
others the star of the book is in many
ways Harry Bridges who was a legendary
longshore worker and union organizer
based in San Francisco originally
Australian you can tell I have an
Australia thing going here and this is a
mural that was done it's in the Rincon
Center this is a version of that mural
of the big strike that he ran in 1934
and that helped the workers be
transformed from what were called the
sort of they were the rats of the wharf
and they became the Lords of the dock
right so what he was able to do in that
Union and some other unions were able to
do is not something most unions did but
it's still an interesting way to figure
out if this is possible was through a
variety of institutional arrangements
governance a ring
educational arrangements to evoke from
membership a commitment to act on behalf
in the interest of others who they would
never see with whom they had no
impersonal reciprocal relationship and
how did we do that how are we able to
figure that out and to demonstrate it we
looked at archives we did interviews
with people who were still alive though
we had all this interview material from
the long past we looked at the
conventions and the kinds of arguments
and debates at the educational
institutions and not just in these
unions that did this but also in unions
that didn't in order to so the
comparison is another critical part
always having a comparison set either
implied or explicit in order to
understand the conditions under which
these kinds of changes in belief would
take place and when they wouldn't and
under what conditions you might evoke
for people this commitment to act in the
interest of others I want to get one
more from the room I actually want to
quickly though paraphrase and then we'll
and then everyone's gonna have a drink
or two because we have a little bit more
time but we want you to stay and our
speaker as always sticks around to have
a more one-on-one conversation and it's
important don't line up she's gonna be
you're gonna be signing books I think
John will come over in sign books or
revokes we got books tonight
but not an easy book to read I told a
better story than its a read I just have
to warn you before you spend all your
money John had to get tenure we had to
meet certain
so there's some more questions to ask
but to paraphrase a question that came
in from the our livestream folks what do
you do about when not just false news
but that false knowledge if you will
starts to build up a body and starts to
have a you know its own in some ways
mimicking what what happens with with
real ciyon i think about i I once upon a
time had done some work in like tobacco
control issues and so forth and the the
fake grassroots organizations and the
fake science that was funded by
corporations sometimes with an interest
is there anything in academia or is
there because clearly the news doesn't
do a good job of well we can't count on
the news there's some good journalism
out there still certainly and by the way
Dan Gilmore speaking for us in October
so to the question about fake news he's
a veteran journalist and a great
journalist and he's going to be talking
about the future of journalism and and
some of the problems today so look out
for that one as well but but thoughts
about that is is there is is there
anything in academia or anything you
know what helps us in society with
combating and an organized mimicry of
what looks like good science if you will
well I think the problem is is even
worse than you're describing it because
if you know in my talk I mentioned a
report that was circulated by the social
science guy on NPR I've read things in
the New York Times science section or
you know so it's not just Fox News or
the the group's the grassroot groups
it's a deeper misunderstanding of when
something it's back to the question of
when something should be disseminated
and when it shouldn't be and the
incentives in the universities still
encourage publication even when there
shouldn't be publication you know that's
not it's not a fully create it's not a
fully justified finding and people will
write we were in a conversation today
about a Nobel economist who is a former
casbahs fellow James Heckman who's a
brilliant
but he's written on the same experiment
as somebody said more more times than
there were even multiples more times
than there were subjects in the
experiment you know so at some point
you're the incentives are screwy so
material is getting out there that then
gets reported as truth which is still
first of all there is no truth in that
exact sense and second of all it's it
it's being picked up faster than it can
be really refuted appropriately so some
of that is the responsibility of
academics and transforming our own
incentives so that we're not encouraging
that kind of behavior and some of it I
think is other kinds of things that we
as academics can do which we're not
always good at some are some aren't
which is really figuring out ways to
disseminate information in a better way
so it's both more credible and it's also
clearer about just what the state of
that knowledge is that it you know
sometimes it's a process it's not that
it's it's absolutely firm now there are
things where we know for sure that
they're like the tobacco has delet
terrible effects on people and where
there was a big campaign to of
disinformation climate change is another
one those are different kinds of
problems because I don't think academics
can do a lot about refuting big money
that's being poured into disinformation
except to keep yelling and saying wait a
minute that's not the story and
hopefully not getting roped in as an
accomplice in that's right money do we
have one more question over here
great last question yeah I was wondering
why you didn't mention the printing
press in your organizational knowledge
and I know it's a distribution channel
but such a powerful one
I didn't mention a lot of things I was
really trying to think about not just
the tools the things that happened but
really the organization's the
institutions rather than the
technologies so I could have gone on and
on about telescopes and microscopes you
know there are lots of technologies and
the printing press is one of the most
important that have really transformed
access to information and distribution
of information the contemporary one is
the data transformation you know which
is really changing what we have
available to process for science so
there are multiple ones of that I didn't
mention because I was focused on
something else another talk and I want
to mention as we're ending on that the
the a couple pointers I mean a bunch of
pointers to former casbah speakers are
coming to mind even in the printing
press question with Jennifer Peterson
talk this past year one is just a
pointer if you I don't know some of you
have seen George Tyson's talk about the
Institute for Advanced Study at
Princeton which was referenced earlier
it's a really interesting talking I
think an interesting comparison here and
I'll will post that to our social
channels as well as the remind me of the
Nobel Prize I think the basic talk which
is are actually re up on the the event
thing we'll put that out there
so I think there's nothing left but to
say thank you and thank you for being a
great audience
thank you you stick around bring more
questions up here I've got about a
hundred
[Applause]
[Music]